c'est en se présentant par le fleuve
saint laurent dans la réserve mohawk
d'akwesasne et que la ministre de la
sécurité publique a voulu symboliquement
lancé un message on a traversé tout à
l'heure la frontière la peine plus loin
qu'ici on est la frontière entre les
eaux canadiennes les eaux américaines
fait qu'on voit très bien que ça peut
être facile d'accéder ce qui fait qu'ils
vont une patrouille nautique 24 c'est
d'ici que ya déjà des arts où ils sont
saisis des arrestations qui seront faits
qui vont en avoir probablement encore
plus considérée comme l'une des
principales routes de contrebande
d'armes à feu à quoi ça ce n'est est
utilisé par le crime organisé parce
qu'elle était la fois au canada et aux
états unis en plus de bénéficier du
fleuve saint laurent au moment où trois
fusillades ont éclaté en moins de 6
heures à montréal la nuit dernière
geneviève guilbaud annonce un
investissement de 6 millions pour les
cinq prochaines années dans la réserve
mohawk l'argent servira à ajouter des
véhicules tout terrain et surtout un
bateau supplémentaires pour la police
dacquois ça ce n'est la partie
québécoise du fleuve saint-laurent sera
maintenant surveiller en tout temps ce
qu'on vient dire aux gens qui ont des
mauvaises intentions c'est qu'en tout
temps en tout lieu maintenant nous avons
une patrouille qui sera disponible que
ce soit en bateau ce sont maintenant
joue en 4 ou pour le chef de police
dacquois stationner cet argent lui
servira également à embaucher cinq
policiers supplémentaires pour augmenter
la surveillance ou des controverses la
ligne on est plus position les dessins
de citoyens donc on peut plus être donné
à 100 de principe ce la même chose sur
le lot donc je suis assez les techniques
d'enquêté l'efficacité de mes policy
d'efficacité des équipements que nous
avons qui font en sorte qu'on réussit à
faire l'arrestation des gens cassé il
estime avoir le bateau l'annnonce du
jour serait un pas dans la bonne
direction selon plusieurs analystes
un moyen limité au québec mais ça montre
une volonté politique de combattre les
réseaux qui sont bien établis selon
l'agencé des services frontaliers
le nombre d'armes à feu illégales
saisies a presque doublé en cinq ans
québec espère maintenant que ses
partenaires en ontario ou dans l'état
new york vont augmenter la surveillance
autour de la réserve en refermant cette
porte d'entrée la ministre geneviève
guilbaud fait le pari qu'elle pourra
ralentir le trafic d'armes à feu
illégales qui se retrouvent dans les
rues de montréal ici pascal robidas
radio-canada dans la réserve à quoi ça
ce n'est